si elle était capable de produire un amour qui dure,
pas juste une étincelle, mais un vrai amour, un amour durable.
Mais je ne me sentais pas capable de répondre à cette question.
Ma propre relation n'avait que quelques mois,
et j'avais l'impression que les gens posaient la mauvaise question.
Qu'est-ce que cela leur apporterait de savoir si nous étions toujours ensemble ?
Si la réponse était non,
cela ferait-il perdre de la valeur à cette expérience
des questions ?
Le docteur Arthur Aron est le premier à avoir traité ces questions
dans son étude de 1997.
Le but du chercheur n'était pas de créer un amour.
Il voulait plutôt encourager
la proximité interpersonnelle entre les étudiants à l'université,
en utilisant ce qu'Aron appelait
« l'auto-divulgation personnalisée maintenue, croissante, réciproque ».
Cela semble romantique, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais l'étude a fonctionné.
Les participants se sentaient plus proches après cette étude
et plusieurs études par la suite ont aussi utilisé le protocole
d'Aron pour se faire rapidement des amis
pour instaurer rapidement confiance et intimité entre des inconnus.
Il a été utilisé entre des membres de la police et d'une communauté,
et sur des personnes ayant des idéologies politiques opposées.
La version originale de l'histoire,
celle que j'ai essayée l'été dernier,
les paires de questions personnelles avec 4 minutes de contact visuel,
cet article y fait référence,
mais il n'a malheureusement jamais été publié.
Il y a quelques mois, j'ai donné une conférence
aux Beaux-Arts.
Un étudiant est venu me voir à la fin
et m'a dit, timidement :
« J'ai essayé votre étude et cela n'a pas fonctionné ».
Il semblait un peu consterné.
« Vous voulez dire que vous n'êtes pas tombé amoureux de la personne
avec laquelle vous l'avez essayée ? » ai-je demandé.
« Eh bien, il a observé une pause,
je crois qu'elle veut qu'on reste amis. »
« Mais êtes-vous devenus de meilleurs amis ? ai-je demandé.
Avez-vous eu l'impression de vraiment vous connaître après l'étude ? »
Il a acquiescé.
« Dans ce cas, cela a fonctionné », j'ai dit.
Je ne pense pas que c'était la réponse qu'il attendait.
En fait, je ne pense pas que c'est la réponse qu'aucun d'entre nous attend
quand il est question d'amour.
Je suis tombée sur cette étude pour la première fois
quand j'avais 29 ans.
Je traversais une rupture douloureuse.
Nous étions ensemble depuis mes 20 ans,
ce qui représente toute ma vie adulte.
Il était mon premier grand amour
et je ne savais pas comment vivre sans lui.
Je me suis donc tournée vers la science.
J'ai cherché tout ce que je pouvais trouver
sur la science relative à l'amour.
Je pense que j'espérais que cela me guérirait de mon mal-être.
Je ne sais pas si je m'en rendais compte à ce moment-là,
je pensais faire des recherches pour le livre que j'écrivais,
mais, après coup, cela semble évident.
J'espérais qu'en m'armant de la connaissance de l'amour,
je n'aurais peut-être jamais à me sentir aussi mal et seule qu'à ce moment-là.
Et toute cette connaissance a, d'une certaine façon, été utile.
Je suis plus patiente en amour, plus détendue.
Je suis plus confiante pour demander ce que je veux.
Mais je peux aussi me voir moi-même plus distinctement.
Je peux voir que ce que je veux est parfois plus
que ce que je peux raisonnablement demander.
Ce que je veux de l'amour est une garantie,
pas d'être aimée aujourd'hui
et d'être aimée demain,
mais que cette personne m'aimera indéfiniment.
Peut-être est-ce cette possibilité d'une garantie
que les gens questionnaient
quand ils voulaient savoir si nous étions toujours ensemble.
L'histoire racontée par les médias sur les 36 questions
était qu'il y aurait peut-être un raccourci pour tomber amoureux.
Il y aurait une façon d'atténuer les risques.
C'est une histoire très attirante
parce que tomber amoureux est un sentiment génial
mais aussi terrifiant.
Le moment où vous admettez que vous aimez quelqu'un,
vous admettez que vous avez beaucoup à perdre.
Il est vrai que ces questions fournissent un mécanisme
permettant d'apprendre à connaître quelqu'un rapidement
et que cette personne apprenne à nous connaître.
Je pense que c'est ce que la plupart d'entre nous recherchent en amour :
être connu, vu et compris.
Mais je pense que quand il s'agit d'amour,
nous acceptons trop facilement la version courte de l'histoire.
La version de l'histoire qui demande : « Êtes-vous toujours ensemble ? »
et qui est contentée par un oui ou un non.
A la place de cette question,
je proposerais de poser des questions plus difficiles,
comme par exemple :
Comment décidez-vous qui mérite votre amour
et qui ne le mérite pas ?
Comment restez-vous amoureux quand les choses se compliquent,
et comment savez-vous quand vous défiler ?
Comment vivez-vous avec le doute
qui s'infiltre inévitablement dans toute relation,
ou, plus difficile encore,
comment vivez-vous avec le doute de votre partenaire ?
Je ne connais pas nécessairement la réponse à ces questions,
mais je pense que c'est un bon début pour avoir une conversation approfondie
sur ce que cela représente d'être amoureux.
Si vous le voulez,
la version courte de l'histoire de ma relation est :
il y a un an, une connaissance et moi avons fait une étude
conçue pour créer un amour.
Nous sommes tombés amoureux
et nous sommes toujours ensemble
et je suis heureuse.
Mais tomber amoureux n'est pas la même chose que de rester amoureux.
Tomber amoureux, c'est le plus facile.
A la fin de mon article, j'ai écrit : « L'amour n'est pas arrivé.
Nous sommes amoureux parce que nous l'avons tous les deux choisi. »
Je grince un peu des dents quand je lis cela aujourd'hui,
pas parce que cela n'est pas vrai,
mais parce qu'à ce moment-là, je n'avais pas considéré
tout ce que ce choix impliquait.
Je n'avais pas considéré le nombre de fois où chacun aurait à faire ce choix
et combien de fois je continuerai à devoir faire ce choix
sans savoir s'il me choisirait toujours.
J'aimerais que cela soit assez de poser et répondre à 36 questions
et d'avoir choisi d'aimer quelqu'un de si généreux, gentil et drôle
et d'avoir publié ce choix dans le plus grand journal américain.
Mais, au lieu de cela, ce que j'ai fait a transformé ma relation
en un mythe que je ne crois pas vraiment.
Et ce que je veux, ce que je passerai peut-être ma vie à vouloir,
est que ce mythe soit vrai.
Je veux la fin heureuse qu'implique le titre de mon article.
Il s'avère que c'est
la seule partie de mon article que je n'ai pas écrite.
(Rires)
Mais ce que j'ai, c'est la possibilité d'aimer quelqu'un
et d'espérer qu'il m'aime en retour,
et c'est terrifiant,
mais c'est cela, l'amour.
Merci.